I became extremely suicidal mm-hmm and I
had complete emotional collapse Jada
pinkett-smith revealing it she had what
she calls an emotional breakdown at 20
on her Facebook watch series read Table
Talk I did not know and it broke my
heart
it broke my heart when I heard her
talking about it Jada and her mom Adrian
opened up about that time to eat tea
just weeks ago Jada says she battled
severe depression for years I found out
before the read.table came on but really
just that whole period I had no idea cuz
I really had to figure out a lot of
things for myself and I didn't want to
burden anyone it was about me looking
back at Jada admits she thought success
would solve all of her problems and it
took a while to break that mentality
they put me on Prozac for it was like
five milligrams but once it disrupted my
sex drive I said look that's the only
thing I got in my life I was like for
the one thing that particular wow that
was the thing that got me off of Prozac
Jada says prozac was the only thing that
could get her up in the morning it would
take her hours to get out of bed and now
she says she's off meds and doesn't get
depressed really that's what this table
is about you know is us finding our
truth sometimes discovering our truth
and having the courage to live that
truth
this week's guest Kid Cudi opened up
about his own battle with depression
sharing how he self medicated with
cocaine he's two years clean now and his
revelation led to this confession from
Jada in my depression using ecstasy
drinking a whole lot you know and
smoking a bunch of weed and trying to
just find some peace in my mind I was
doing ecstasy we and a bottle of
Courvoisier I knew I was on my own the
course to addiction at the end of the
episode of Jada reiterated the purpose
of the show to share personal
testimonies so other people know they
are not alone it takes practice to have
those difficult conversations with
kindness and consideration and it's just
something that we have to continue to
practice because if we don't talk about
it we're not going to get to the other
side we're just gonna you know things
are just gonna stay in the cracks and
fester so the more that we can bring
these difficult subjects to light and
talk about it the more we can purify
these subjects and bring them into
something new and so that's why it's
important for me
[Music]
you